I have potentially good news for you
except that it's total BS and what I
mean is that there was a report which if
true would be really great news which is
that the NRA the National Rifle
Association the biggest gun lobby in the
United States they are claiming to have
such deep financial trouble that they
may be unable to continue existing which
would be lovely news except it is very
clearly an attempt to garner more
support and to push back against what
they feel is an unfair case being made
against an insurance program of theirs
by the New York by New York State and
all of this information came from a
document that the NRA filed which
Rolling Stone obtained and what the NRA
is filing says is that because of a
lawsuit that is being brought against
them by New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
and New York state financial regulators
they have become victims of a
blacklisting campaign by the state and
have suffered tens of millions of
dollars in damages and what they claim
is they can't access basic financial
services that they need in order to
operate that they're facing quote
irrecoverable loss and irreparable farm
harm they say that they've lost
insurance coverage that they need for
day-to-day operations that some of their
physical offices are at risk that their
video streaming service and magazine may
have to shut down this is all fantastic
I can't imagine better news here but I
am very clear that these claims are
being completely exaggerated since they
are being made in a filing against New
York State they say that they've been
unfairly targeted by state regulators
over what the state claims is the
illegal sale of NRA branded insurance
for gun owners the NRA was offering this
insurance called carry guard and what
carry guard would do is if you are a gun
owner and member of the NRA and you
legally fire a gun and as a result of
legally firing that gun you incur legal
expenses carry guard NRA insurance will
reimburse you for those
legal expenses lovely little program
that they have isn't it so I think that
if true this would be great news
I want the NRA to disappear they exist
to increase gun sales they exist to make
people afraid of the world so that they
go out and they buy guns and now we are
learning that they also existed during
the 2016 campaign to work as a conduit
between Russia and the Trump campaign
funneling tons of foreign money to
Donald Trump but do I believe even for a
second that the NRA is on the verge of
disappearing obviously not obviously not
the NRA is very clearly exaggerating the
supposedly dire state of their financial
position they're misrepresenting their
financial situation to get donations to
turn people against the state of New
York this is a stunningly well-funded
organization and I don't believe it at
all that they are at risk yeah I too
think it's a fund raising plea
especially because Republicans are in
control of the government now and what
helps the NRA is making the case that
the government is going to take away
your guns and they especially make that
case after like a mass shooting sure
because Republicans are in charge of
everything they can't effectively
communicate that case in the same way
that gun manufacturers have been
suffering when it comes to gun sales
partially because you don't have a
Democrat in the White House that the NRA
is saying he's about to take your guns
maybe the NRA has been suffering mildly
when it comes to membership and so on
and so forth but they've got as we
learned foreign money coming in they've
got domestic money coming in and this is
all a ploy to suggest that the New York
State lawsuit against them is unfair
interference in what the NRA does but
this is a PR campaign it's a bottom line
that's what it is the NRA is not a
responsible organization it's a
political organization it's a business
organization that works exclusively for
gun manufacturers to sell more guns in
more places and there's been a big
campaign on Twitter started to send the
NRA thoughts and prayers which of course
is a reference to how the NRA always
will send thoughts and prayers after
shootings which of course do nothing and
I think it's equally likely that
thoughts and prayer
on Twitter won't do anything for the NRA
suppose it fundraising woes which I
would argue barely barely exist so don't
fall for this although it would be
something to rejoice about if indeed the
NRA went out of business they're not
going out of business and this is just
an attempt to get more money out of
people I'm really thrilled to tell you
that today's program is made possible in
part by better help calm slash Pakman as
many of you know I have been working
very hard on this program to reduce
stigma around mental health to reduce
stigma around seeking help and I have a
family that is very involved in mental
health and if you've not already heard
about better help it is a tremendous
resource better help gives you through
your phone and computer affordable
private access to licensed trained
accredited experienced psychologists
counselors therapists and clinical
social workers who were dedicated to
helping you through whatever is going on
in your life you just go to better help
calm slash Pakman fill out a
questionnaire they will match you with a
counselor that will work best for you
they are LGBT friendly you can even say
I want a counselor who's not religious
if that's important to you if your
initial match isn't a good vibe you can
switch to a different counselor and the
beauty is that not only do you get
unlimited counseling over videophone and
text from at home and on the go it is
way cheaper than in-person counseling
and after three months it becomes even
cheaper for you they also have financial
aid for people who need help paying but
you get the same professional licensed
therapy that you would by going to
someone's office and I believe that so
many people would benefit from therapy
whether you're dealing with an acute
situation in your life whether there are
bigger picture difficulties that you're
experiencing please consider checking
out better help calm / Packman it's easy
to sign up and
started we've put a link in the
description if you're watching on
YouTube once again that is better help
calm slash PA que ma n